entrée dans l'ère du numérique c'est la
volonté première de la région
le haut débit qui couvrait seulement 38
% des lycées en 2015 en couvre cette
année 58 % l'objectif à terme est de
s'étendre d'ici 2020 à 100 % des
établissements afin de combler les
disparités entre paris et la banlieue
toujours plus connecté les professeurs
et lycéens vont avoir l'occasion de
découvrir la nouvelle plateforme
collaborative mon lycée point net et
l'idée c'est d'avoir une plate forme de
réunions open source qui permettent à
tous les professeurs d'échanger entre
eux mais entre lycées à tous les élèves
d'échanger avec les professeurs aux
élèves de travailler entre adoptée par
270 lycée cette année mon lycée point
net promet d'être plus adaptée et
efficace que le dispositif lily mis en
place en 2009
en fait il est vraiment centré sur les
usages un an l'usagé c'est qui pour nous
c'est les professeurs et les lycéens
essentiellement donc une grande
simplicité la possibilité de créer son
sa propre interface c'est à dire de
personnaliser son portail on s'est
vraiment appuyé sur les modèles des
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui le suivi
quotidien des lycées va lui aussi être
informatisé puisque les établissements
se verront remettre un carnet de santé
en ligne avec toutes les informations
sur le lycée qui seront transmises
directement la région pour permettre la
maintenance plus facile pour permettre
les travaux les réparations les
rénovations à travers ces différentes
initiatives
la région espère contribuer à la lutte
contre le décrochage scolaire qui touche
25 mille jeunes franciliens
chaque année